for kyle muller tom not the first time
he's pitched on his whole mound first
time he's done it as a starting pitcher
for the braves today his six-game
hitting streak come to an end
and mueller
three pitches three strikes in his first
strikeout one up one down i don't know
i've ever seen a guy go out there and
throw three straight breaking balls to
start a game but when you're getting
swings like that keep throwing it
32 counts he knows he can't continue to
do that yeah that's playing with fire
for sure and here's his first 3-2 count
today and he got marty out on a check
swing
they rang him up at the plate
scott berry says strike three two up two
down for more
and the two two pitch
has cut out a missed hay strikes out the
side in his home debut as an atlanta
starter
and the braves are coming up no score
after a half inning
[Applause]
and hopefully we don't have any issues
like we had yesterday
2-2
that a well-executed fastball at the
bottom of the zone for sandy alcatra
gets his first strike out of the
afternoon and there are two ways and i
think you're going to see a lot of this
from sandy today maybe not messing
around so much talking about that 100
mile an hour fastball he's on his game
he's just pounding the low zone to sink
no score top of the third runner at
second
one ball one strike one out for jaztism
maybe early in that series against the
dodgers ground ball right side that's
through for a base hit
run will come in to score birdie in
easily and the marlins have a one
nothing lead in the third well that sack
punt pays off that's what you love to
see even the lefty lefty matchup with
jazz at the top
3-1 ripped into left field that'll get
down for a base hit jazz is coming
around third he's going to score martay
heading to third and
coop is out
but it is an rbi single and martay heads
to third marlins take a two-nothing lead
well they've successfully turned it into
a crooked number that's what you wanted
to see from the marlins building off of
each other a good swing in the back by
coupe on a 3-1 pitch and he did
everything right on
runner goes throw from alfaro is
in time
[Applause]
cunha scotland has caught stealing for
the second out here in the third inning
well he got a pretty good jump of course
sandy on the mound
and a great throw from alfaro my
goodness did he get an awful lot on the
throw and got it out of the glove quick
tag got him in the left forearm
just before he got to the bag
strikeouts
in on the hands grounded to short
bobbled by jazz recovers and just in
time
to get riley
that'll end the inning sandy strands a
couple
[Music]
getting into that
quick rhythm
as this one is chopped up the middle
jazz biggie over to first a double play
that's the first hit by anybody in this
series not named albies or freeman miggy
makes the play deep in the whole long
throw and gets kevin smith
what a play by miguel rojas
two nothing after four
got to come up with at least one here
trailing two to nothing
shift on for ozzy
and the middle infielders on the right
side are back
the pitch
swung on hit hard through into right
field base hit
that gets a cunha in freddy will stop at
second
and ozzy albee's first pitch swinging
lines a base hit to right field and it's
two to one miami
give ozzie his 59th rbi
garrett cooper leads off inning number
six for the fish they lead two to one
now
and he drives one on the first pitch
deep to right acuna tries to deak him
and that ball is going to sail out of
here a line drive homer
so a good start for the marlins in the
sixth inning against mueller after the
braves get a run in the bottom of the
fifth inning cooper connects on a solo
shot yeah that's what you love to see
from the big guy coop
big swing off the bat going the other
way
adrianza at 259 on the year add somebody
on and get a cuny and freeman
and adrianza the one two
is cork toward left
sanchez on the run still going still
going it hits him in the weather and
drops and adrianza will end up at second
base
that ball kept tailing away from the
miami left fielder had the glasses on
hit him in the glove and he couldn't put
the squeeze on it there's a big break
like you say the gifts keep coming
so cash it in they've cashed in one of
them need a couple more strikes nobody
out
3-1 game in the seventh and floral with
a called strike three
on a pitch up and in
and that's how they retire cuny junior
yeah well done by so many guys try to go
in there and they
miss badly freddie freeman makes it a
one-run game
second hit 46th rbi the braves have a
couple of unearned runs
muscled it over the second baseman for
an rbi single
here it comes and a ground ball to third
birdie up with it throw to first is low
buddy gets him
and dylan flores strands a couple braves
get one
3-2 after seven
late in this one 3-2 marlins near the
bottom of the eighth
ground ball miggy slides gets up and
gets the out at second base what a play
by miguel rojas
wow marlins fans i'm telling you it has
been a treat today
and a ground ball to third birdie
panic
aguilar another double play turned by
the marlins that's three today
and they protect a one-run lead going to
the ninth
[Music]
bottom of the ninth a one-run game again
garcia on to try to finish this one off
the braves have the pitcher spot due up
2-2
called strike three
once again pounding that up and in
corner
that's where they got him in the seventh
they get him again in the ninth
yeah continue to attack albus but do not
want to make a mistake
down in the zone he has been all over
velocity today turning around a couple
of 99 mile an hour fastballs
and hits this one to right field duvall
is there
it's a marlins win
a one-run win for the marlins
again they have played in a million of
these games this year but this one goes
their way as they split the first two
games with the braves
nip and tuck the whole day